>> YOU HAVE ACCUSED PAKISTAN'S
CURRENT PRIME MINISTER, THE
INTERIOR MINISTER, AND A SENIOR
INTELLIGENCE OFFICIAL FOR THE
ATTACK ON YOUR LIFE.
THESE ARE SERIOUS ALLEGATIONS.
WHAT'S YOUR EVIDENCE?
>> WELL, BECKY, ABOUT TWO
MONTHS AGO, THIS PLOT WAS
CONCEIVED.
I WENT ON IN PUBLIC.
I WENT ON THE 24TH OF SEPTEMBER
AND ANNOUNCED THE PLOT.
LET ME GIVE YOU THE BACKGROUND.
HOW DO I KNOW THAT WHAT I AM
SAYING AND WHAT EVIDENCE I HAVE?
IT STARTED OUT WHEN I WAS
DEPOSED FROM GOVERNMENT.
FROM THEN ONWARDS, WHAT WAS
EXPECTED WAS THAT OUR PARTY
WOULD JUST FALL APART.
WHAT HAS IN FACT HAPPENED IS
THAT THOSE TWO FAMILIES BEING
AGAIN IMPOSED ON US WHO HAVE
BEEN RULING FOR 30 YEARS, THERE
WAS A BIG PUBLIC BACKLASH.
RATHER THAN MY PARTY GOING DOWN,
IT HAS BROUGHT THE PARTY SUCH
PUBLIC SUPPORT.
WE WANT 75% OF THE ELECTIONS
SINCE WE WERE OUT OF POWER.
ALL EFFORTS WERE MADE TO MAKE
IT OUT OF THE RACE TO
DISQUALIFY ME.
>> THAT BACKGROUND WE KNOW.
WITH RESPECT, I ASKED YOU FOR
THE EVIDENCE BEHIND THE
ALLEGATIONS.
>> BECKY, AND WITH RESPECT, IF
PEOPLE DON'T KNOW THE
BACKGROUND, HOW WOULD THEY KNOW
WHY THIS ATTEMPTED TOOK PLACE?
THE REASON WHY THEY HAVE TRIED
EVERYTHING TO SOMEHOW GET ME
OUT OF THE WAY, WHEN THAT
DIDN'T HAPPEN, THIS WAS
PLANNED.
TWO MONTHS AGO, AN AGENCY
PRODUCES THIS VIDEO WHICH
ACCUSES ME OF BLASPHEMY.
THERE'S A JOURNALIST WHO WAS
LINKED WITH THESE AGENCIES
COMES UP WITH THIS VIDEO SAYING
HOW I HAD OFFENDED THE
RELIGIOUS SENTIMENTS OF THE
PEOPLE.
THE RULING PARTY INFORMATION
MINISTER ALONG WITH THE
DAUGHTER OF THE FORMER PRIME
MINISTER, MARIAM, THEY THEN GO
ON TELEVISION AND SAY HOW I
HAVE UPSET THE SENTIMENTS OF
THE PEOPLE.
IT IS THEN THAT I WENT ON AIR
AND SAID THIS IS A PLANTING.
IF THEY ASSASSINATED ME, THE
EVIDENCE WOULD GO ON THE
GOVERNMENT.
THEY MADE IT OUT THAT IT WAS A
RELIGIOUS FANATIC WHO IS GOING
TO KILL ME AND THEN PUT --
>> LET ME PUT THIS TO YOU.
YOUR ALLEGATIONS HAVE BEEN
AGGRESSIVELY REFUTED.
I HAVE TO PUT THIS TO YOU.
PAKISTAN'S PRIME MINISTER HAS
CONDEMNED THE ATTACK ON HER
LIFE, WISHING YOU A SPEEDY
RECOVERY ON HIS TWITTER.
THE INTERIOR MINISTER HAS
REJECTED YOUR ACCUSATIONS.
THIS IS SUCH A GRIEVOUS
STATEMENT.
IT HAPPENED IN THE PROVINCE
WHERE --
THE MILITARY HAS ALSO ISSUED
THIS STATEMENT, SAYING, IN PART,
QUOTE, THE BASELESS AND
IRRESPONSIBLE ALLEGATIONS BY
CHAIRMAN PTI AGAINST THE
INSTITUTION, PARTICULARLY A
SENIOR ARMY OFFICER, ARE
ABSOLUTELY UNACCEPTABLE AND
UNCALLED FOR.
PAKISTAN'S ARMY PRIDES ITSELF
FOR BEING AN EXTREMELY
PROFESSIONAL AND WELL
DISCIPLINED ORGANIZATION WITH A
ROBUST AND HIGHLY EFFECTIVE
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM,
APPLICABLE ACROSS THE BOARD FOR
LAWFUL ACTS COMMITTED BY
UNIFORMED PERSONNEL.
PAKISTAN'S MINISTRY OF
INFORMATION RELEASED A VIDEO
THAT CNN CANNOT VERIFY.
THERE WAS A CONFESSION FROM AN
UNNAMED MAN WHO WOULD CLAIMS
CARRY OUT THE ATTACK.
IN THAT VIDEO, THE MAN SAID HE
WANTED TO KILL YOU BECAUSE YOU
WERE MISLEADING THE PEOPLE.
IS IT NOT CONCEIVABLE THAT THE
PERPETRATOR WAS ACTING ALONE
AGAINST YOU AND YOUR PARTY'S
POLICIES?
>> FIRST OF ALL, THERE WERE TWO
SHOOTERS.
THERE WAS DEFINITELY MAYBE
ANOTHER ONE.
THERE WAS THIS GUY WHO FIRED
THE FIRST VOLLEY AND I FELL.
OTHER PEOPLE FELL BECAUSE HE
GOT OUR LEGS.
WE WERE SAVED BECAUSE ONE OF
THE PEOPLE IN THE CROWD PUT HIS
GUN DOWN.
OTHERWISE, WE WOULD HAVE ENDED.
THERE WAS ANOTHER PERSON WHO
CAME IN.
THE VOLLEY CAME OVER OUR HEADS.
IT WAS A PLANNED ASSASSINATION
ATTEMPT.
WE WENT ON AIR BEFOREHAND.
I WARNED THEM THAT THIS IS WHAT
IS GOING TO HAPPEN.
AFTER THE ATTACK, THE THINGS
THAT HAVE HAPPENED, THE
COVER-UP THAT IS GOING ON --
THAT IS WHY I'VE CALLED FOR AN
INDEPENDENT INVESTIGATION.
IF AN INDEPENDENT OR PROPER
INVESTIGATION IS TO BE DONE,
WITH THEM ON TOP, IT CAN NEVER
HAPPEN.
I HAVE APPEALED TO THE CHIEF
JUSTICE OF PAKISTAN WHO HAS --
IF I AM IN THE WRONG, THE
INQUIRY WOULD BE WRONG.
I KNOW THE SEQUENCE OF EVENTS.
I KNOW THE GOVERNMENT THAT TOOK
PLACE.
THE SWAB WAS PLANNED.
IT WAS FIVE MONTHS AGO.
>> YOU HAVE BLAMED THE U.S. AND
OTHER ACTORS FOR OUSTING YOU AS
PRIME MINISTER.
YOU HAVE MADE IT ABUNDANTLY
CLEAR TO RETURN TO POWER.
WOULDN'T ACCUSING THE CURRENT
GOVERNOR WITHOUT PROOF WORK IN
FAVOR OF YOUR POLITICAL
ENDEAVORS?
THAT IS CERTAINLY WHAT YOUR
CRITICS ARE SUGGESTING.
>> BECKY, I DON'T NEED ANY
REASON TO ACCUSE THIS
GOVERNMENT FOR ME TO GET BACK
INTO POWER.
ALL OF THE OPINION --
THIS IS THE MOST POPULAR PARTY.
WE DON'T NEED TO ACCUSE PEOPLE
OF ASSASSINATION SO THAT YOU
GET MORE POPULAR IN THIS
COUNTRY.
WE KNOW WHAT IS HAPPENING.
THE TWO PEOPLE I HAVE ACCUSED,
THE PRIME MINISTER AND THE
INTERIOR MINISTER, BOTH HAVE
BEEN ACCUSED FOR A MASSACRE.
12 PEOPLE WERE MASSACRED AT
ABOUT 60 WERE HIT WITH BULLETS
WHEN THE POLICE OPENED FIRE AT
AN UNARMED CROWD WHICH IS HOW
YOU DO A POLITICAL PROTEST.
IT'S CALLED THE --
THEY HAVE BEEN ACCUSED OF
KILLING PEOPLE, ASSASSINATION,
EXTRA --
THIS IS NOT THE FIRST TIME THEY
HAVE DONE IT.
AS FAR AS THE INTELLIGENCE
AGENCY, THE OFFICER, WE KNOW
HOW THE EVIDENCE WAS, HOW THE
SOLE PLOT OPENED UP.
WE KNOW HOW THE VIDEO, WHO MADE
THE VIDEO, HOW IT WAS
ORCHESTRATED, AND THE COVER-UP
THAT IS TAKING PLACE.
>> OKAY.
>> IT WAS ON TELEVISION.
HOW WAS THIS GUY ALLOWED TO --
>> I AM HEARING YOUR
ACCUSATIONS.
LET ME PUT THIS TO YOU.
LET ME JUST PUT THIS TO YOU.
PAKISTAN'S ELECTRONIC MEDIA
REGULATORY AUTHORITY HAD
INITIALLY ISSUED A BAN ON AIR
OR NEAR SPEECHES.
THAT WAS NOT UNTIL THE PRIME
MINISTER HIMSELF USED HIS
EXECUTIVE ORDER TO REVERSE THAT
PLAN.
SOME WILL SEE THAT AS A SHOW OF
GOOD FAITH IN LIGHT OF YOUR
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST HIM.
DO YOU SEE IT AS SUCH.
?
>> I DO THINK THE SHUTDOWN ON
MEDIA IS UNPRECEDENTED.
ONE OF THE BEST INVESTIGATIVE
JOURNALISTS IN PAKISTAN WAS
ASSASSINATED IN KENYA JUST A
COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO.
THIS GUY WAS EXPOSING THIS
WHOLE PROJECT WHICH TOOK PLACE
AGAINST ME.
HE WAS HOUNDED OUT OF PAKISTAN.
HE ENDED UP GOING TO DO BY.
FROM THERE, HE WENT TO KENYA
WHERE HE WAS KILLED.
THEY WERE TWO OF MY CLOSEST
AIDES.
ONE WAS A SENATOR.
HE WAS STRIPPED NAKED,
TORTURED.
BOTH BLAMED THE SENIOR
INTELLIGENCE OFFICER WHO WAS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE TORTURE.
LOOK, THE CLAMPDOWN THAT HAS
TAKEN PLACE ON MEDIA IS
UNPRECEDENTED IN PAKISTAN.
TO SUDDENLY THINK THAT YOU WILL
LIFT THE BAN ON ME, IT WOULD
NOT HAVE WITHSTOOD AND A COURT
OF LAW.
IN WHAT PLACES WHERE THEY
BANNED ME?
BY THE WAY, HOW COME I, AS A
PERSON WHO WAS ABOUT TO BE
ASSASSINATED, WHY CAN'T I NAME
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE SUSPICIOUS
ABOUT WHO PLANNED THIS ATTEMPT
ON ME?
>> YOU CONTINUE TO CALL THIS AN
ASSASSINATION ATTEMPT.
YOU SAY YOU HAD EVIDENCE IS
GOING TO HAPPEN BEFOREHAND.
YOU SAY NOW THAT YOU WANT AN
INDEPENDENT INVESTIGATION.
I WONDER WHAT INFORMATION YOU
WERE GIVEN AND FROM WHO TO
SUPPORT THOSE ALLEGATIONS?
>> NUMBER ONE, VICKY, ON THE
24TH OF SEPTEMBER, THERE WAS MY
PUBLIC SPEECH WHERE AS THE
EVENTS UNFOLDED DURING THAT
SPEECH HOW THIS WOULD HAPPEN,
HOW IN THE NAME OF BLASPHEMY A
RELIGIOUS FANATIC WOULD KILL ME
AND THEY WOULD BLAME IT ON HIM.
ALL OF THIS WAS IN MY SPEECH
WHICH I PUT ON TELEVISION AND
SOCIAL MEDIA.
SECONDLY, REMEMBER THREE AND A
HALF YEARS AGO I WAS IN POWER.
I HAVE CONNECTIONS WITH
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES, THE
DIFFERENT AGENCIES WHICH
OPERATE.
HOW DID I GET THE INFORMATION?
FROM WITHIN THE INTELLIGENCE
AGENCIES.
WHY?
MOST PEOPLE ARE APPALLED BY
WHAT IS GOING ON IN THIS
COUNTRY.
MOST PEOPLE THINK WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN PAKISTAN IS
UNPRECEDENTED.
I WAS A GENERAL OF MARTIAL LAW.
I WAS PUT IN JAIL.
NEVER DID THE SORT OF
OPPRESSION THAT IS GOING ON
RIGHT NOW IN PAKISTAN, IT NEVER
HAPPENED --
>> ALL RIGHT.
IMRAN KHAN, WE'VE RUN OUT OF
TIME.
I THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
THE POINT OF VIEW OF THE FORMER
PRIME MINISTER.
LISTEN, SIR, WE WISH YOU A
SPEEDY RECOVERY.